Daily Mail has this America's Aderall
shortage is driving ADHD patients to use
meth in its place social workers have
claimed the US Food and Drugs
Administration announced an official
Aderall shortage in October 2022 that
people are still struggling to get their
hands on the medication over a year
later people can become reliant on the
drug meaning that if they stop taking it
suddenly they cannot think or function
properly this dependence can drive
people with ADHD to the black market to
get their dopamine hit both meth and
adol are amphetamines and Central
Nervous stimulants which help address
the dopamine imbalance in people with
ADHD uh the whole thing about a the
dopamine balance with that that's all
fake but that's not true that's
misinformation um there is certainly no
uh wellestablished link between dopamine
IMB chemical imbalance in ADHD we hear
about the the chemical imbalance with
all kinds of uh these different mental
disorders and they're just stated as a
fact oh there's an
imbalance okay well I have to ask again
if that's the case
then why don't they diagnose ADHD with a
brain scan they don't do
they now they diagnose ADHD and then
maybe they'll go back later and look at
the
brain and then try to try to uh kind of
like reverse engineer it oh well okay
we've already established this person as
ADHD right now we're looking at the
brain and let's find in the brain the
things to prove the determination we
already made regardless of what's
happened chemically in the brain
anyway um Garrett Royer a licensed
social worker in New York who counsels
people who use drugs told The Daily
Beast that clients who have ADHD but
have never tried meth before have
started inquiring about safer meth use
inquiring about the effects saying I
can't get my medication I need to find
something to help me function okay well
this is great isn't it we've got a bunch
of people looking uh for
methamphetamine um thank you big Pharma
H have we had enough of this
yet have we are we done with it yet
we've created a nation of drug addicts a
big well we let me no it's not we big
Pharma has created a nation of drug
addicts and they've done it by
convincing healthy people that they're
sick and convincing parents that their
healthy children are sick and then
prescribing stuff that will actually
make them sick to cure the fake
illness and now we've got a bunch of
meth addicts who think they need meth to
cure them of being easily
distracted I mean think about that it's
Madness I can't focus let me get some
meth
um here's what everyone needs to
understand we are never going to be free
from the clutches of big PHA as long as
you take some weak sauce stance like oh
yeah those disorders are overdiagnosed
ADHD is overdiagnosed no it's not
overdiagnosed for the s same reason that
that I would never say that um sightings
of the tooth fairy are over reported
okay no it's just it's just made up okay
it's
manufactured ADHD is a manufactured
illness just like so many other illness
especially psychiatric illnesses that
big Pharma has
invented and then
monetized oh no ADHD isn't made up you
don't understand my my seven-year-old
son is always really distracted all the
time oh really your seven-year-old son
your seven-year-old boy is high
energy has trouble focusing you mean
like every other seven-year-old who's
who's ever
lived and oh wait your kid is distracted
while living in a world surrounded by
screens and noise and lights and sounds
and images all the
time so he's distracted while being
totally surrounded by
distractions same for you you might say
no me I have ADHD I and I know that I
have ADHD because because I'm so
distracted all the time of course I
could ask you like what's your control
group right you know how your brain
functions how do you know that it's not
supposed to function that way well I
know my brain I have difficult my brain
functions this way I know that it's not
supposed to function that way based on
what have you ever been inside of anyone
else's mind how do you know that this is
not how Minds just
work right I mean that's a very basic
question but it's something to think
about if you look around and you and you
uh respond especially to modern society
by being very distracted unable to focus
and you and you declare that well it
must mean that you have well how do you
know but you don't know anyone else's
mind you haven't lived inside anyone
else's body or experienced their own
their mental States or their inner life
so you have no idea whether your way of
responding uh to the outside world is is
normal or not you don't
know and I got news for you the
psychiatrists and counselors and
therapists you go to they don't know
either okay they're not experts in The
Human Condition they're not these are
not Gods okay they're not living inside
anyone else's mind
either they they they have just come up
with an arbitrary idea of how minds are
supposed to work and how people are
supposed to
behave and and that's the standard that
they're holding you against and then
they drug you like they have their
standard that they've made up and then
they give you drugs to bring you up to
that
level it's worth asking like how do you
know so you go to a therapist and you
say here's how I am here's how I
function and they say well you're not
supposed to function that way how do you
know that who told you that since the
overturning of roie Wade the left has
lost their minds leftism is their
religion and abortion is their official
Sacrament meanwhile pro-life efforts
which are now more important than ever
are booming as one of the largest
pro-life organizations in the world no
one is in a better position than 40 Days
for life to end abortion state byst
state they've opened a record number of
locations since gr is overturned and
they continue to grow in volunteers they
now have 1 million Volunteers in 1500
cities 40 Days for life holds peaceful
vigils outside abortion facilities in an
effort to change hearts and Minds in the
most blue pro-abortion States you can
help 40 Days for Life fight ongoing
legal battles to protect free speech for
their volunteers by giving a tax
deductible gift of any amount at 40 days
forlife.com that's 40 days forlife.com
and especially with something like this
right now again I mean there there are
obvious cases somebody's hearing voices
having hallucinations like clearly that
is not normal it's not supposed to be
that way but if it's something
like I have trouble focusing I'm
distracted well yeah everybody that's
true of everybody yeah but for me it's
extra it's like more than normal so this
is a totally normal like hearing voic
ISM and hallucinating that's not normal
at in any degree at all if you do that
at all then it's not there's a problem
but being distractive not being able to
focus that is totally normal everybody
in the world struggles with it but what
we're being told is that it's normal but
if it like but there's a baseline And if
you go a little bit above the Baseline
now it's a mental illness it's not just
a variation of Personality right it's a
mental
illness you you don't have to think
about that very long to realize how
ridiculous it is and how arbitrary it is
and how just impossible
to quantify it is
um so we we can continue
uh with this strategy with creating a
nation of meth
addicts um or we can consider that maybe
this is all made up okay like maybe big
Pharma and psychiatric industry they are
making
up
illnesses and why would they do it
because they make billions of dollars
off of it it's not this is not a
far-fetched
far-flung uh conspiracy theory maybe a
conspiracy theory but it it's it's you
don't have to speculate about what the
motivations would be okay we have people
in these positions who if there's some
new mental illness that comes along that
means billions of dollars for them and
so are they motivated to come up with
these mental illnesses and diagnose them
hell yeah they
are so what's your what's our response
to that well that's they would never do
that that's the big farmer would never
do that come
on Not only would they do it we know
they do
it
um and uh you
know many people are victims of it like
many people who are otherwise very
skeptical of big Pharma you know sort of
are theoretically skeptical of big
Pharma have themselves Fallen victim to
this and they don't realize how how it
applies to them and their own
kids hey YouTube thanks for listening to
the show if you'd like access to my full
show with no ads you should go to
dailywire.com and use promo code Walsh
to get two months free on all annual
plans see you there